police work in marijuana I identified
really quick I'm not a marijuana
Advocate but I identified really quick
that this is ridiculous that this is
against the law every single person I
ever came in contact that was stoned
never gave me a problem at all in fact
they were some of the best contacts I
ever had wow Best Contacts I identified
really early that this is something
that's just it needs to go away every
dude that was drunk was a nightmare and
that was legal and this is not why do we
have those laws against marijuana
because I old white people you know back
in the day yeah just hysteria
they didn't know what it was they didn't
understand I don't know I don't know why
but Devil's lettuce or whatever all that
[__] yeah but we're getting better
California is good the rest world's
getting better I really believe they
should be legal everywhere for sure 100
percent